jaison's with us in Los Angeles hi Jason
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well my wife and I just
got married about ten months ago and we
signed up for financial peace next month
and we have about twelve thousand
dollars on four different credit cards
in debt no student loans and we're
trying to pay that off and I know your
debt snowball has a really helped us a
lot good but our interest rates on those
cards go from 6% to about 15% and I
wanted to know your opinion on a 18
month zero interest balance transfer to
have all those cards on one card making
one payment what's your household income
about seventy-five thousand and how much
other debt do you have other than this
twelve thousand I have a car note that
all about 11000 M okay so you should be
debt-free in about a year okay that's
$22,000 in a year right making seventy
five you ought to be able to do that so
what we're discussing here then is out
of $22,000 in debt if you move this
credit card ten thousand dollars or so
twelve thousand dollars this credit card
debt to zero and the average card was
about you said six to fifteen so let's
say ten interest then that means you're
going to save about twelve hundred
dollars right okay and twelve hundred
ollars is nice if you send it to me I'll
keep it but twelve hundred dollars does
not fix the twenty two thousand dollar
problem right so the moral of the story
is this when people do debt
consolidation or balance transfers the
danger is you feel like you did
something and you didn't twelve hundred
dollars doesn't fix this problem you
following it
so ninety percent of you getting out of
debt is you getting on a plan you guys
getting in this class you're getting
fired up and wired up and getting in
attack mode ten percent of you getting
out of debt is adjusting interest rates
so the answer to your question is yeah
move it to an on to a zero balance or a
zero interest transfer
you want but the danger Jason is is that
in your emotions you feel like you
somehow did something no you just you
just nicked it you haven't cut it yet
watch it I want you whale on this thing
okay do I need to ask them if what
percent interest would be at the end if
it's not paid up and also you got to get
everybody you got to get it paid off
right it's got to be gone in the year
right if it's 18 months zero interest
you want to worry about it you can move
it it's fine it's because the interest
is not the problem even if they go back
to charging you interest if they go back
to charging you interest cuz you don't
get this paid off then you didn't hear
anything or talking about cuz you can
get there so no you you've got to say
okay I moved it but that is really not
the problem we're going to get really
mad at this debt we're going to cut our
lifestyle we're going to get on a
written plan that gets you out of debt
not saving on the interest interest
rates not your problem your problem is
you've been spending more than you make
and you're not been attacking it now
you're ready to attack it you're going
to do it and stick with it that's what I
would do this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim
Oh